That wasn't fair that she can go live and accuse me of this [__]
and it's totally fine to leave up there, but but you remove this?
>> I get called a everywhere I go.
Stop saying it's something that you could just do man like do
you don't get it. Like saying I'm a middling creator what is
>> You guys missed it. Miskif did a stream where he was
um
about this which is just unfortunate.
I understand why he's upset about it. I do get why he's upset
about it.
I do.
I cannot avow
the behavior of going live
and crying about it. I can't avow it. I can't avow it because
for a couple reasons. First of all strategically okay, it's not
a good look. Not a good look at all. All right. Um two, it doesn't
help you going forward at all. Like it's it's already a bad look,
but it doesn't help you going forward. And that's really what
you should be worried about is how you're going to move going
forward how you're going to like continue on with
It it just it can't be this man. It can't be this. It it can't
be. I'm going to understand by the way. I will feel empathetic
to every single thing he says here okay.
I will. I'll feel empathetic to all of it. I'll understand exactly
why he's
I'm not I'm not going to say that like you can't be upset by
this. You can be upset by whatever you want. It's just
It's just about what is good for you. You're doing like drama
content. This is good when you're doing drama content. Bad move
okay. I It sucks cuz I've been where Miskif is. Not I don't think
ever on the like
But um like in real life I've been where he is where you've got
that thing that's like in your brain and it's [__]
up every aspect of your life. It's like you have a friend group
where you feel super betrayed, right? And it's like
up every aspect of your life. You can't go to your friends, you
can't go to like your family for some It's like everything you
just see it everywhere.
And you can't get out of your brain. I've been there, man. So,
I I'm sympathetic, but unfortunately, none of this is good, right?
Like dwelling in it, constantly bringing yourself back to it,
wallowing in it, never good, never works, never makes it better,
always makes it worse. In fact, Um I thought Miz said, "I hate
all these people. They're not my real friends. They're fake as
fuck." Well, I think Yeah, it's but it's Listen, Miz's career
is streamer, and so he has to have this thrown in his face all
the time. There's really only one way to move forward with stuff
like this, right? It's to integrate this thing that you're being
made fun of like into your content,
right? That's all you could do. Like you're going to have to
joke.
You're going to have to joke about looking the other way with
rabbits. You're going to have to joke about moving a little too
fast. You're going to have to joke. Maybe you throw a Trump joke
in there. Sometimes they just let you do it when you when you're
the head of OTK, sometimes they just let you Okay, you're going
to have to roll it in cuz you got no other choice.
Otherwise, this will haunt you. It will ruin your day every single
time it comes up, right? Cuz here's the fact of the
Emiru could have lied about all of this, and every
single person calling you a would still call you a You could
find DMs of her basically be like colluding with Asmongold and
Tectone to make you look like a And all the people who hate you
would still be calling you a There is no going back. There is
no going into the past and making it right and fixing everything,
okay?
I understand that it sucks.
I do The The sh- thing is is like I think there's like a way
back,
but you have to figure out who is worth going back to. I do think
there's like a way if you're not just everybody of going back
and making some of those friends again. Yeah, it's like it's
all over. There's a lot of different things going on. It's like
you have to be able to move on with your life. If you can't move
on with your
I don't I don't know.
I I've no good advice if you if you really can't move on at all,
are you you just have to. You have to force it, right? Like I
think I said once before it's like you you just burn the boats,
man. There is no going back. You're on you're on a new island.
You're on a new adventure. There is no going back to the old
life, okay? You can make this work. I know you can make this
work. He's got a big community still. And also he's lucky stuff
like this is not I think this is not as bad whatever he like
starts crying here. This is like not as bad. You shouldn't do
it. I would never recommend doing this like making yourself vulnerable,
right? Not a good not a good idea, especially if you're going
to do drama streaming. Cuz people will pile on and it'll make
it worse, right? What was your situation? Um I was just out of
high school and I had it's like I had a friend who I went on
a trip with. I told him while we were drinking that I was like
really into this girl. Then when we got back, he immediately
he immediately asked that girl out before I could. And but but
when we were drinking and hanging out, he was like, "Oh man,
you got to ask her out. You got to ask her out. That would be
awesome if you guys hung out if you guys were together." It was
like all big upping and then snaked me, okay?
And it it me up. It was really It was It was And then I found
out that he'd done it to other guys, too. Other guys in our friend
group. And I'm like, "Bro, >> off, gay."
Off. Yeah, but that was me like I was young and I didn't know
like I I didn't know to just move on. It was the whole like you
you get obsessed with somebody and then it you move on.
Or you you don't move on. But for me it's like it's still like
only I don't know a month or two. Feel bad, but this is really
funny. I don't I'm friends with the guy now. I actually don't
think it was like that big of a deal. Um he he told well, I don't
He might be like an [__]
but we were pretty hammered.
Like thinking back, we were pretty
And I couldn't I couldn't like let it go at the time, but we
eventually we both ended up doing like computer science and working
in the same areas. You stayed friends with him? No, I totally
nexted him and then like 2 or 3 years later I became friends
with him again. This is a little worse. Okay, this is a little
worse that he had like a huge business that is kind of taking
a hit from all [__] happens, man.
I I I mean, what happened is I mean, dude, it's just been hard
chat. I I I ever since Emmy lied and said the [__]
she said, it's been so [__] hard.
Um it's been [__] tough. I mean, it's been [__]
tough, man.
Uh I I get called a [__] [__] you
I've lost every one of my friends that I had for 8 years.
>> I try to I try to say this. He obviously didn't watch
my coverage of it from before, but it was like I really
I really think he could make peace with a couple of these people
and like put it behind him. He doesn't have to make peace with
like Tectone and Asmongold. I feel like Tectone and Asmongold
wanted to frame this in such a way that they could like end his
career. That's totally They were totally malicious about it,
right? They're They wanted to take no prisoners. They wanted
to like kill this guy, right?
I don't think he has to let that go. But with the Emmy thing,
I get how
some of the stuff she describes in the relationship, it's like
yeah, that's that all sounds like pretty rough, man. And I don't
think you'd like hold it against her totally. I don't think you're
going to ever be happy holding that against her and treating
cuz it unfortunately, he's kind of got Pink up here in the corner.
There are some parallels. I don't think there's parallels in
the conduct of the in terms of the assault, like the allegation
itself. I I don't think there's a parallel in terms of the conduct.
I think Miz was obviously way less brutal, way less um like he
he wasn't trying to violate the consent, there wasn't anything
like that, right? But after the fact, there is a similar element
in that the other person told said what they felt happened. The
other person told their
because of how third parties interpreted that and used it against
Mizkif, he blames the woman for that story being
while I I understand that, you
you'll never ever ever be happy trying to like make that person
pay or something. That's not a way to happiness, right? Cuz realistically,
they they did something that like I don't know, it doesn't seem
that wrong to me, you know what I mean? So, I'm not saying he's
like Tectone in any of the conduct that preceded, but in the
follow-up, there is a like element in that he's taking the the
the allegation she made and instead of going, well, there you
go. It's like a he said, she said and she's saying it's her emotional
opinion and she's not even really making the
I feel like there's a way you play this where you just say, that's
her admitting that like this really didn't necessarily happen
and I hope you guys take that
I'm happy to put this behind me now,
I think that's what you do here. I think you you have to be able
to let it go and you have to not blame when when somebody calls
you a That's what it is. That's dog [__] man. That
sucks.
You just have to be like, yeah, that person doesn't care. That
person was going to call me some name. They choose this cuz they
think it hurts Doesn't affect me cuz that person's a loser. If
there's somebody who's just willing to go around and use this
label, they don't actually care. They They're just a loser with
no time. They don't have anything. I'm like, I'm better than
them, right? It's like the Brandon Buckingham Perry thing.
Like you're you're better than that Act like it.
Stop giving total [__] losers on the internet a piece
of your time when they don't deserve it.
Right? Don't give them a piece of your time or piece of your
mind. Now, it's easier said than done, especially when he's getting
like when he's this upset. Anyway, we keep going. >> Everyone
that we used to interact with, I've lost so many friends, fans,
respect. I worked 8 years my [__] ass off every [__]
day
you know, be a good content creator and do [__] for
you guys and
I know I I didn't I'm not perfect and I know I've [__]
up, but um
Yeah, it's been tough.
Obviously, the past few months. >> Sorry, I'm laughing
at the Asian girl in the background.
He's about to like pour his soul out and
still Asian girl just comes in to get her headphones.
Just speed it up a little bit.
Um and I Hold on. This chat is going off. Damn.
Hold on. You're a lying buddy killer.
>> You're a lying buddy killer. Damn, dog.
And I Damn. It's been I mean, you know what's been hard. Like
it's You're not stupid. Getting accused of being a by your ex-girlfriend
right after she comes back from
and tries to and ruins your life. I mean, dude, it sucks, man.
I don't want to leave my house because I'm afraid to get called
a racist.
Yeah, I
Has he thought about not living in LA?
really think hard about never saying this stuff. I know it it,
dude. Once you're in these kinds of internet
it's got to go in the pit. It can't go to your audience, man.
It can't anymore. You can't say this is what really upsets me.
You You've opted for a content model where where if you go live
and you say, "This is what really upsets me most in the whole
you are yourself over, okay? There are audiences here. There
are creators here who will weaponize that against you
The second you say it, right?
He never thinks through this [__] at all. Well, it's
tough cuz he went from a a type of content where he could have
these kinds of conversations and it was fine. He was like the
super wholesome
And now he's at a type of content where it's not like that. And
so it's tough. There's a learning curve.
Um he's going to have to work the thing. He's going to have to
integrate it somehow, okay? You know how Jordan Peterson tells
you, "Integrate your shadow." He's got to integrate the I hear
or something, okay? He's got to integrate the what people call
him a He's got to have a joke. He's got to have something that
he's just like claps back with and he is water off a duck's back,
okay?
As good You got to do it, man. There's nothing else.
Did he move to LA from Austin? Yeah, I think he moved from to
LA from Austin. >> Think about it every second of the day.
It's all I think about. Of course it's all I think about. >> Yeah,
it's rough.
I don't know how he got over the um the assault stuff. I think
he kind of got over it, right? This At least he's overcome this
kind of problem once before, so he should be able to do it one
more time. >> I get
Someone that you're with for 3 years just going out and saying
you're raping
>> Sucks, man. JonTron P is just chilling. JonTron P is
chillaxing.
>> Uh so
Um just I'm not going to I'm going to go over this in more detail
later.
I do want to say I appreciate you guys for being here. And you
guys are like the last people, you know.
I do appreciate it. That you guys
>> I didn't believe it that you did any research at all
and can understand that I didn't do what she said. And and I
get it. She's the girl streamer, right? Popular girl Um that
everyone loved and I'm a
comes off as a douchebag.
I didn't do anything to deserve this, dude. And it kills me.
It kills me. >> That I I people don't do anything to deserve
cancer. You got to push through it, man. Sometimes it doesn't
matter. Sometimes bad stuff happens to you that you did nothing
to deserve. Now,
I wouldn't say you deserve to get called You guys had a [__]
up relationship that when it came out was going to kind of blow
you up your reputation a little bit. Like that's just facts.
I would say you don't maybe deserve to get called a but you were
going to get made fun of all the time. I just I'm just The idea
it's also going to be [__] up if you always think
I did nothing to deserve this.
That prevents any retro that prevents any introspection, any
retrospective. You can't look at it and fix mistakes. I did nothing
to deserve this. That's like a that's an attitude you have when
you don't want to learn.
And you should probably learn.
>> I hate it, man.
And I don't have a voice anymore to
I No one wants to listen, man.
No one wants to listen.
You know? That's what's I don't have a voice. Like I I you know.
Um if you don't know, I'll just say this for now.
Emmy responded to my
claims that she obviously defamed me about sexual assault, talking,
everything else.
>> Going to speed through this part. I don't think she
lied about some of the
Certainly the Some of it was subjective.
>> She responded last night after 4 and 1/2
It took her 4 and 1/2 months to respond. And her response Anyway,
I'm going to speed through this part. She describes exactly what
happened to her. And although she defines it as sexual assault,
a reasonable viewer would unquestionably understand that the
term is her own description of what happened to her. The viewer
is not left to guess as to the nature of the assault based solely
on the term sexual assault. She straight up says it.
Right there. And no one will listen to her. She says it right.
>> Oh, man. I Am I out of my mind? I feel like I'm going
to just Dude, Miz is going to hate me. Don't watch this, Mizkif.
Don't watch this. I don't think she's saying she doesn't think
it's sexual assault.
I think the lawyer's making a stupid argument. I don't think
that
I don't think that that's implied by what the lawyer's arguing
though. The lawyer's making a really stupid argument. I actually
I thought when I saw all the other people like piling on and
saying Emiru totally lied,
thought that's what I was going to find out. But now that I'm
looking at the posts and stuff, I don't think that's what it's
saying, man.
No, I think she believes it's legal
I think technically assault is like non-consensual touching,
right? Non-consensual touching. She believes she didn't consent.
That is her That's her mental state, right? She didn't consent
and she was touched. Like that's It's sort of like bingo bango,
that's it right there. You know what I'm saying?
That's it.
So while the lawyer's making this argument that like, "Oh, well,
a reasonable viewer would say it's like her emotional description
of what
I still think her actual description of what happened is assault.
Mostly evidenced that she wrote it down in a totally dispassionate
way. Like the lawyer's making stupid arguments here. So I don't
know how it goes in the legal case, but it seems like Emiru wrote
down herself that she thought it was assault before she started
recounting the details and she kind of stood on that. Now, whether
or not she was, you know, sort of convinced to do so by some
other hard to say. >> And no one will listen to me. It's
[__]
I [__] said it no one listens to chat. It's assault.
He said it right >> [__] I don't want to I
just want my friends, man. I just want my friends. I hate this
[__] It sucks. >> This does suck, but
I It sucks cuz I feel like um I'm the kind of person who I see
stuff like this and I I had to train myself like for a long part
of my life
to not
to not immediately acquiesce to somebody in this state. I had
to do that, okay? Cuz I I my natural instinct is to go, "Oh,
you're crying, you're upset. I want to take care of you. That's
like who I am, okay?
Unfortunately, Miz,
I work in a job now where I can't do this. I can't I can't be
that guy. I can't even be the guy who I can't do this, either.
And you're kind of trying to do that, too. We probably
I'm It's And it's nothing to do with the fact that you cried.
Men can cry. I don't give a [__]
But like we probably can't be friends if
if you have this reaction
to like
to people talking [__] about you on the Cuz I will
If you are friends with me,
if you're friends with me, people will do that to you. If you're
friends with me, if you're if you're friends with Queenman, people
will do that to you. There will be people around who will say
that [__] to you. We do have viewers who will say
the most evil [__] out of nowhere just to upset the
streamer. I have a lot of viewers who are totally broken individuals
who do [__] like
So, I I feel like it sucks cuz I I want I want to be gentle,
but at the same time it's like, bro, there is no room for this
in this line of work. And like the drama in the drama sphere,
there is no room for this.
So, I I feel like I need to make it
as much as it makes sense. And I'm not saying you can't have
these emotions. I'm saying you cannot do it on stream.
You You literally can't do it on stream.
And so, I'm not I'm never going to hold this against you, but
this can't happen.
For your sake, not for my sake.
I just I could show up and go, "That guy had a rough day at work.
That's a tough set, buddy." That's a tough set, you know? You
ever hear um You ever hear Dave Chappelle say like he's more
comedian than black dude cuz he he saw like Kramer going off
saying the hard R all over the place, and he's like, "Yeah, I've
been there, man. That's a tough set. YOU COME BACK from it, okay?
You get Get him in the next set, okay?" Right? He He wasn't even
mad about it. It's like, "I'm not mad about this." Like I I get
it. You had a rough stream, whatever. I don't But I'm saying
for your sake you cannot have this happen. If you want to do
the drama content, if you want to go play wild and stuff, that
makes sense. But you can't be you can't be demon time and this
one. You can't do both. I'm fine with you going either way. Also,
you can make mistakes. I just people are going to use this against
you, too, which will snowball really fast if you don't watch
Can't do that, either.
I I understand. If you you just have to make a choice, whether
you want to do this kind of content or you want to put out those
kinds of feelings. It's totally human to put those kinds of feelings
out in the
Literally, I I've seen um I think PPP did this with Anisa when
Anisa did the response to Kino Casino. You It's like listen,
I can be a human being. I've got a whole bunch of people in my
life I'm here I'm a human being with.
But in this one specific field, man,
this will happen. The thing you're describing that you can't
deal with, that will happen to you again and again and again.
So you have a choice. You either get to integrate that, you got
to get to joke about it, you get to like
make it a part of you,
Or you should figure out I you could still stream. Just stream
like video games and play your Mario speed runs, do your state
contract, invest, get some assets, get your money up, and dude,
you don't you don't even have to work again. You just
you just be chilling.
No there's no shame in not wanting to do like the super aggressive
like drama content where you're covering
There's literally nothing There's nothing wrong There's no shame
in that. But if you want to do that kind of content, this cannot
be the This cannot be a response to getting [__]
talked back at you. You don't think Now, I think Tectone deserves
being called the way more than you, but you don't think Tectone
wants to cry sometimes?
You don't think Tectone Tectone had to go and read a whole book
by a Roman emperor named Marcus Aurelius, okay?
To figure out how to control himself, all right?
This is how, you know, Tectone's Tectone's a bro, okay? Tectone's
going to DM him and be like, "Oh man, that was tough. Um you
should read the Meditations. You should read Meditations, okay?
Check it out. Stoicism. You should see about it."
Oh right, Tectone does cry on stream all the time. Never mind,
Tectone also does that. Yeah, Tectone's a total [__]
At least at least Mizkif didn't cry and say he got raped in the
same stream, okay? Multiple times, I think. Yeah.
Hey, it could be worse, man. You could have had Tectone's breakdown.
Ha. Silver linings, boys. Silver linings.
Knocked that one out of the park. Wait. Wait. Mizkif does not
describe himself being assaulted as a child in this stream, does
he? Please tell me he doesn't do that. I need I need one edge
here. We need one edge to work with.
I know he doesn't. I would have I would have heard about it.
You see, I By the way, I'm going to talk as if Mizkif's watching
this. I never know if he's watching it. I really hope he wouldn't
watch it live. But Miz, if you if you're watching this and any
of these jokes hurt you, that's another sign that you got to
harden up or move on.
And it I Trust me. I I wasn't like this naturally, okay? I had
to get used to doing this kind of content. I had to get used
to pushing down the human being in
I'm not making fun of you. I'm doing entertainment, right? I
don't If we were hanging out offline, I would never go
like I would never do this to somebody in real life, right?
the whole point of this is entertainment. This stuff is
All right? So, you can't take it
>> I hate this [__] so much. I really do,
I just want my friends.
>> Bro, my music is inappropriate right
Way too poppy.
>> I hate this [__] >> And her [singing]
They're not your real friends, bro. That hurts even more, man.
Like it hurts even >> Dude, at least he doesn't have to
see you calling it emotional this emotional maybe manipulation.
That's how people will see it. Uh well, now he's going to have
to cuz it's obvious emotional
So, thanks. Microtonal won't take no. Thanks for doing that to
him, okay?
It's obvious Now, is it is it like totally um in control? No,
probably not. It's It's probably something like maladapted
emotional manipulation. I'm not even going to I I don't need
to load the emotional It's obvious emotional manipulation. But,
this like how human beings work, too, right?
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, it's literally full of hell. Any emotion shown is emotional
manipulation. You're like signaling this You're signaling this
out for people so they feel bad for you cuz you feel bad and
you want help.
Yep, that's a normal human being thing to do.
I'm going to keep speeding up for the some of the breaks here.
>> I don't feel like I can't talk about it cuz no one I
can't even talk about it. I don't want
>> Oh, you should definitely find somebody to talk about
it with, by the way. That's required.
Uh if you have nobody to talk about it with, you should get
Find some hobby groups or something. I don't even know. You should
find somebody to talk about it with so that you're not doing
this.
>> Oh, I should shut this off because I'm going to stop
caring about these They're fake as [__] man. Don't
get it. You don't know what it's like, man. I feel
Stop being like it's about the Austin crew, chat.
I get called the everywhere I go.
Stop saying it's something that you could just do, man. Like
dude, you don't get it. I get called the when I go to bars.
You don't know what it's like.
>> How about going to like um like punk bars, like music
bars, okay?
You get called the there and half of the women think that's like
a a plus.
Have you thought about it? I'm just saying. I'm just saying.
Some crazy women go to like punk music bars or rock music bars.
Whatever the [__] you got to get some outfit like
that, okay?
You just got to change up the tactics, maybe. See a silver lining
here. >> Not true, to be honest.
On Discord, they're probably on Discord. >> friends in
Austin, Texas, dude. No one talks to me. I have no friends. I
literally only have Genie. She's my only
>> Here's the thing. This is why I think it's like
especially for people who stream a lot, okay? If you're streaming
like 8 hours a day or something,
I don't know. I keep hearing chud. I think I said that I think
I said to stop the [__] capturing this last stream.
You can have like other streamers you if you collab with that
you could be friends with. That's just how it works, man. Any
job you work at, you're going to have friends. Just look at them
as co-workers. Look at them as people like you can try to form
a deeper connection, but understand that like like I think sales
people would get this that like you could undercut each other
in a way that really helps one of you [__] the other
over. And you're aware of that and you maintain the friendship
being aware of that. That like you're never going to put yourself
in a position where you could be [__] over really
easily by that person cuz you you just need to keep that in mind,
right? Like it's it's just sales people. But the whole idea that
Chud always does this thing, "Oh, I don't have internet friends
at all." [__] you spend like 12 hours a day on the
computer. You don't have internet friends?
You don't have internet friends, you don't have friends. You've
got like guy friends who you call once every 6 months and you
occasionally like talk to in that way. Those aren't friends.
Those are like acquaintances that also are kind of bored sometimes.
And listen, maybe you go, you catch up and they're like whatever.
They're like
Like it's like you never missed a day of hanging out all the
time. That's fine.
But why you got to why you got to cap and act like bro, Chud
streams more than anybody. Chud streams like a full 8-hour stream
on YouTube and then like a 2-hour stream on Kick before that.
He streams like 10 hours a day. He's got to spend at least an
hour or so getting content. Bro, you are here on your computer
like 12 hours a day. You talk about you don't have friends.
I sure hope that's not true cuz that would really suck, okay?
I know he said he has IRL friends. WHEN IS HE HANGING OUT WITH
THOSE IRL friends, Noah Tannenbaum? Never. Although Chud is a
kid, so it's a little different. I think for parents it's pretty
different.
I It is a little different for for parents. Parents have like
their kids and that takes up a lot of time that friends would
normally take up. So, I do think it's he gets like kind of a
pass on that one. And it's also like a social interaction as
much as they're not like hearing your problems or whatever. So
long as you're not like needing to vent your problems, it's probably
fine to just you know, you get a lot of
social validation, social stuff out of your kids. That guy has
kids? Shockingly, yes.
HE WAS ATTRACTED TO WOMEN WITH NO extra parts at some point.
Shocking, I know.
>> Sorry, I've been crying all day. It's not just now.
>> I'm going to tell Trihex you said this.
All right.
I'm not telling I'm not saying he has to be friends with me.
I'm not saying he's friends with somebody on the internet. I'm
just saying that like me, if you don't get social interaction
out of anything
and you're streaming as much as he does, that feels like that
would be rough. I think he has a like a partner or something
though. You also get stuff out of that.
>> I mean, with friends like DK and Stylo, he doesn't need
more any more enemies. That's true. I don't know if I don't know
if I'm guessing him and Stylo are like
Yeah, like I don't He's also around and presenting that like
him and Keemstar and Stylo and DK aren't friends. Like he's actually
totalable. Maybe they don't hang around as much as they used
to, but they're definitely friends.
A betrayal from one of those guys would hurt a lot. And he's
he's totally faking it if he acts if he acts otherwise, okay?
Those guys who went with him from like his old community to his
new community, like who went with him through that DGG interchange
and like took his side there, pretending those aren't his friends
at all. I'm guessing his real life friends are closer, but still.
Come on, man.
>> Nothing's changed, dude. You're so dumb. >> You
think nothing's changed, man? I can't that there's sometimes
co-workers I call them [__] man, like everywhere
I go, my life is full of babies, you know? Stop saying it, just
stop it. Dude, just
>> Oh, man.
Cognitive behavioral therapy, Miz. Cognitive behavioral therapy
will teach you how to do this. Teach you how to get through this.
Okay? Cognitive behavioral therapy is how you get out of this,
cuz when he there's like this thing, um
when you when you have like something that really [__]
with you, like uh like you basically have triggers. Imagine you
have like triggers, okay? And for Miz, getting called a racist
is like a trigger and it brings him back to like a bad time and
it makes him think of like the things he's lost and all of this
bad [__] right? It's like he's sailing a ship and
when he gets called a racist, it's like he's suddenly in like
a whirlpool that's going to suck him down into this like vortex
where he can't stop thinking about all of these things,
It's um That's what's going to happen to him. And so, he needs
to go to like a a cognitive behavioral therapist and figure out
how to break that spiral,
You just need like a couple jokes, all right? You roll with the
punches. Not even a thing. It's not even a thing. You can get
over it. It's actually fine.
Like I feel like and maybe this is just me.
I don't know. It could be irritating.
Like when people were calling me like an anti-Semite, it irritated
me a couple years ago when I first started streaming. That irritated
me.
I think I had like a not dissimilar reaction at first where I
was like very angry about it. I felt totally unfair. And then
I just realized that the people who were saying it like actually
don't care about the facts. They're just going to say that no
matter what cuz they just like me. And eventually, once you like
once I realized that, I was fine. I just moved on. I I correct
people still, but it's like it doesn't like send me through a
loop or something.
Now you are an anti-Semite, so it doesn't bother you.
Now I wish I was an anti-Semite cuz that's what Israel deserves,
but I'm not cuz I, you know, was raised on after-school specials
where kids of every color and creed got along.
That is what they would deserve, but I can't bring myself to
do it, okay? I was just I was propagandized as as a kid to
believing a colorblind meritocracy is the only way, all right?
It's up. I would love to be racist, but I'm I'm probably just
not.
Uh it's clearly different if you're recognized in public. That's
true. That would be worse, but if you're I mean for you it affects
your job. It's it's kind of
Yeah, it's kind of a little bit the same, right?
It's a little bit the same, I think. Luckily for me as well,
Nick Fuentes has done tremendous work in making anti-Semitism
cool.
So, there's also that. Well, like if somebody could somehow rehab
the reputation of general
like generally for in the way Nick Fuentes has done for anti-Semites,
then maybe Miz would be less sad. But, that just I haven't seen
that happen yet,
Russell Brand tried.
Didn't make it work. >> And she waits 4 and 1/2 months
to stall this [__] out so no one cares anymore. And
her [__] response is that. Like, are you kidding
me? And no one cares >> I can't believe you're I wasn't
pretending you would get straight or get taken off of YouTube.
I said precisely there's no way this is against YouTube
I said that. I said that exactly. There is no way this is against
YouTube TOS, and she told me not to risk it. So, I had to respect
it.
Like, what are you What am I going to
No, you don't understand straight or gay. Your outfit is way
closer to breaking TOS than any clip I have of Nick Fuentes,
okay? Well, not any clip clip with the L F N clip. Oh, by the
way
I I should still I should make it very obvious. I don't believe
Mizkif did sexual assault. I don't believe Mizkif is like a consent
violator.
I don't think any part of that story makes it sound like he's
a consent
I don't think he should be called a rapist. I think it is like
wrong to call him a rapist.
Spiritually, Tectone is rapist tone, okay? Spiritually and literally,
he is rapist tone. Mizkif is not a rapist.
That's how I feel about it. He's raping himself right now, a
little bit, okay? Oh, wait. I don't know even I hopefully I even
know why he covers this
>> She's just lying right here. She didn't end the relationship,
I did. I walked right out of that door. Why is she lying? I I
I [__] ended the relationship.
>> So inconsequential. And this is like this reminds me
of Zena a lot, like the Zena Daria stuff. It's like the kind
of thing that Zena and Daria would get mad about, right?
But it's like it really all that all that's happening here
like you and this other person cared about each other and you
can't believe that the other person is saying and doing things
that go back on that, go back on this relationship. You both
feel hurt. You're both going to say and do things that kind of
like
go back and forth and it's just it's like a [__]
situation.
Yeah, I'm not saying that towards Cameron. Not towards Cameron.
Not doing it.
>> Like saying I'm a middling creator, what is what?
>> That's [__] up, man.
That's tough.
>> Shanks is at the top of her field. Shanks is best known
for live streaming videos on Twitch where she plays video games
and post cosplays and speaks directly to her viewers. She is
one of the most popular female streamers on Twitch with millions
of followers across her platforms. She was recently profiled
in Forbes 30 under 30 list as >> Why is he reading this
angrily? All of that I I unfortunately for him all of that is
>> The head of the games category which described her as
the most watched female streamer on Twitch.
>> Why is he saying it? Dude, that's all
This Emiru.
I didn't know she was that huge.
King of what? Really? She is like the biggest female streamer
on Twitch. Now there's accusations of view botting and she gets
raided a lot by Asmongold, okay? Asmongold's really feeding viewers
to her all the time. >> I don't know why it says this is
my last name. My last name is Ronaldo.
I believe you.
>> I didn't I sucks. Sucks to have that hole in the open
like that.
>> Just came in. What happened, bro?
Not the definition.
My the >> Sorry, I got to back it up to just where this
is going.
>> Amy responded to the my the assault allegations, right?
Um that she said 4 and 1/2 months ago. And her
response to the assault was that
>> her emotional telling of assault.
Not the definition.
And although she defines it as assault, a reasonable viewer would
unquestionably understand that the term is her own description
of what happened to her. The viewer is not left to guess as to
nature of the assault based solely on the term
>> Both of them have made everyone
She said like, "I care about real victims and that's why I'm
coming out about this is to protect women." But it's been 4 and
1/2 months. I don't have a voice. Everyone took that voice from
me. Everyone did. >> The The sh- thing is like I I'm glad
that I'm a smaller creator cuz I think
like I disagree with what he's saying
But I totally agree that he should be called the ri- Like I I'm
going to disagree that this is her recanting. I don't think this
is her recanting. >> that voice. I don't have a voice.
I This is not going any No one No one cares. I still don't [laughter]
know what to do, chat. I'm so I'm [__] up.
I don't know what to do.
You don't know what to do.
>> Um hm, should we come up Should we sh- Should we try
to
uh Should we try to like um
like brain blast some jokes for Miz when people say this to him?
Wait, he's crying? Yeah, he already cried once. This is the second
time he's
we We should try to brainstorm some jokes for this guy, okay?
Somebody calls Excuse me. Hey, you're that
You try running towards them.
You could definitely imply you raped them. I feel like I feel
like it's like
And you'll never forget that night. Something along those lines.
But I'm really tired, so
And two spirit fingers? That's That's not bad. That's pretty
funny.
>> Only Iran? Uh that's gay. Gay joke.
That's not what your mom said. Gay joke.
Kitty joke.
Let me rephrase for being called the You got to lean into it.
You got to lean into it.
You should have seen the outfit.
Are you in therapy? >> That's a tough one. I need another
provider. I'm not kidding you. The provider I was with said that
I'm too I'm too depressed and mentally messed up for her. So
I have to go to another person.
>> Dude, why do dude DUDE DON'T STOP. STOP TALKING on your
stream. Stop talking on your stream.
Why would you Why would you say this? Why would you say this?
Why would you say
Uh it is kind of funny though.
No, I listen. My therapist couldn't handle me.
I just want to make it clear. I literally have no judgement whatsoever.
Literally no judgement whatsoever. For somebody who's just like
mentally
if he felt the same thing any of the things he said or or expressed,
you just say it like in the background with each
Right? Or with your friends or whatever, you just say it like
offline to people. It's not even a big deal, man. It just don't
do it on the stream. Don't do it on the live, dog.
>> But I promise >> Don't do it on the live.
>> And I'm not lying. It'll be in the court stuff. You'll
see it later on, chat. I'm not lying about that [__]
My doctor My therapist really did say that. >> Uh thank
you for the raid, dickgers. If you just raided, thank you.
>> I have really bad PTSD.
>> Yeah, it's I think it's there's different kinds of therapy
you could do. I Depending on what else you got, I I do think
CBT is uh good.
>> I hate I hate that this happened to my career. I hate
that I'm so embarrassed
to be Mizkif. I hate that. I I hate that you guys are embarrassed
to watch me. Like I hate all of it. I hate it so much. >> Who's
embarrassed to watch you, bro? Nobody's embarrassed to watch
you. THE ONLY TIME I'VE BEEN EMBARRASSED to watch me is is this
moment right now.
Literally just this moment. This is the only moment where in
the entire time I've watched Miz from before when he was big.
I didn't watch him when he was in Ice Poseidon. That might have
been embarrassing. I don't remember. But like this is the only
thing I've ever felt like it was was bad. And it's just like
a mistake. You can come back from
Listen, this is probably this is way less bad than the other
mistakes you've come back from, to be honest. This is way less
bad than the Adriana thing.
It's not going to [__] you up at all. Like not at
all. Biologist, thank you for the five gifted. Let's go. Let's
go. Let's go. Thank you very Thank you very much.
Yeah, this is not anywhere near as bad as I You're You're You're
locked and loaded, buddy. You got this. You got
>> Like you got to stop You got to stop saying [__]
like I I feel embarrassed to stream. I feel embarrassed that
you guys watch Dude, come on, man.
>> I hate that I can't tell people what I do for a job
cuz I don't want them to find out what I
>> I got to accuse them like
>> It sucks. >> We stay, bro. >> You already
fought so hard. >> This is one of those moments where like
Mizkif really doesn't understand how It's so [__]
up. Cuz like
Mizkif's at like
How do I put this?
If I'm at like 5%, Mizkif's at like 98%,
okay? In terms of how high his career
Like where where the career of like streamer goes or is. I'm
at like maybe 10% or 20%. He's at like 95% 98%, okay? Maybe we
can break it down to like I'm like 5%, he's like 70% or something.
There's so much [snorts] further to drop off if you do stuff
like this. That's That's like I'm not saying that to make him
worried. It's just like, "Bro, you got to got to get a hold of
it cuz you still have like hundreds of totally dedicated fans.
Like totally dedicated fans. They're like hundreds.
Uh thousands. You What? You have like 6,000 viewers or something?
Right? The what you gamble and [__]
Dude, if I play World of Warcraft, I've got like five chatters.
Okay? I only get chatters if I'm doing stuff like this. If I'm
playing World of Warcraft, I get nobody. Okay? Which is part
of the problem with playing World of Warcraft for me. But I get
nothing. Like you And by the way, I still have so much further
I could fall in terms of like if I were to lose
Like there was a decent period of time where I was struggling
to hit 400 viewers on Kick. Right after like maybe around
like June of last year. I was like having a hard time hitting
like 400 viewers on Kick. Okay? So like I know I have way further
I could fall down. Way
further I could fall down.
>> There's more than just what this is by the way. This
is
her whole thing she wrote is insane.
It's insane.
It's so insane chat that even Henry Basil is is on my side and
said it's insane. And he hates me.
>> Sure sure sure sure. I was talking about living almost
anywhere else Gregor
Miz, we love you bro. Never forget that we love you.
>> I know.
>> Okay, he's doing a lot of >> That's her emotional
interpretation of >> The deed there. Okay, we're going
to go to the I think we go forward a little bit and there's some
other stuff stuff that gets posted here, okay? Oh, what is the
what is Asian girl talking about?
>> How'd she roll in? Genie rolled in? What's going on
with Genie? >> Genie, give this man a hug.
>> I'm like a cactus cuz I have emotions.
>> What a [__] What a [__] What
the hell? She like walks over, is like staring at him, looks
him right in the eyes and goes, "Are you crying?" Dude, what
the
He's live. Oh, her name is Genie. The girl is Genie. I don't
think it's the Genie TV person.
Genie, oh Genie.
>> I don't think Genie gave him a hug.
I've heard I've heard that this girl is not dating Misquif. I
don't think they are dating, to be honest with you.
I've heard
contrary facts there, okay?
Are they doing it? I got no idea. Oh, hold on. >> Time
to go gay. >> So, Misquif, I've heard Misquif pulls open
LSF and some [__] pops off.
Take a look.
>> Hey, so next time I go on a date and a guy kisses me
and I get mad at him, I'll say he raped me.
>> Okay, not helping.
Not helping the image, okay? You shouldn't come on and pile on
women. That's pretty weird. I
Oh, not a good Not a good look, man.
>> He should have practiced his fake crying way more before
bringing it to
>> Dude, why did she say that? Why did she say that?
There was a stream where they both were really open about the
implications as she was talking [__] on the doctor
uh for being fat. If they're they are both trying to suppress
their feelings at least in so far as they
>> You could call them by your ex in front of millions
of people and your life is ruined and you're not allowed to cry
or be upset about it.
>> Uh, yeah, that's that's basically the job description,
yep. Yep. Yep, that's basically the job
>> She's playing with
>> Wait, it's not going up and down. >> I'm not going
to do it, too. >> Hey, it's going to be a slow journey.
>> I know, but it
I mean, you know. >> Miskif's like genuinely entertaining.
This is like the Like I do think you need
I was I I don't want to rub it in, but it's like the Dude, why
is there a chatter named Yellow Fever Patient Zero in his chat?
Miskif Miskif's chatting in his own chat? That's crazy. That's
wild. You hate to see it. >> Like unfortunately,
people don't want to listen to you, and they're not, whatever
you say.
Um but eventually
>> I think the sad thing is what Miskif needs to under-
I mean, I think he does understand it. Maybe this is part of
what's depressing, is the fact of the matter literally doesn't
matter. It It It literally doesn't. It will never matter.
Which is tough. Tough to wrap your head >> comes, and it
should comes out.
And slowly it is.
>> And it's also because you played this character online,
so it's really hard for people to even want to listen to >> I
know. >> Wajins Wajins are yellow fever. Klein Heilo. Wajins
are yellow fever. You're into Wajins, you're into You You do
have it, okay. I'm sorry. Miskif's job is to oral farm, and it
said he's doing this Yeah, it's not good. Okay, I've criticized
it a lot. Now, maybe I should have gone and just grabbed clips
for this instead of watching him like be upset the whole time.
You know what I'm saying? I probably did this to him a little
bit by just watching the vod.
yeah, it's um
you know, you just want to play games. That's fine. You just
want to play games. That's But you can't do this if you want
to do drama, okay?
Got to be built diff.
I love you MizzyWizzy, yo.
You think ChudLogic did what Dude, I hate to say it, but like
I don't think you should copy all elements, but like that that
that I think that Destiny allegations are actually probably significantly
worse than the Mischa stuff. Like even
Yeah, I Sorry, they're definitely worse. I'm thinking like if
Mischa stuff was true, then it's like more debatable.
Um or if it was like less it was more muddy. It was harder to
see what was going on with Mischa stuff. I'm just trying to think.
And like Destiny when he came out and talked about it, he was
confident, right? You never could catch Destiny crying on a stream.
Listen, you want to get away with murder, that's the guy you
want, okay? He can show up, he do terrible He can show up and
he can just be totally fine. You got to be like that a little
bit as a streamer if you got bad [__] happening in
the background, okay?
He was behind the scenes? Yeah, but everyone's going to do that
behind the
>> It's been a long four months. >> If Destiny can
get away with it, Mischa can get away with not r-
Just to be clear, Destiny only r- in a metaphorical or electronic
sense, okay? Consent violation, not a physical
All right.
Does not have the muscle mass for it.
>> Oh, we don't want to do the r- hierarchy too much, Trigger.
The total pool of r- is complicated and fraught with peril. >> everything
is out and then people apologize to you. >> Y'all dude
is right.
>> And then you can go out.
it would be a pretty sick That would be a pretty sick tier list,
okay? We should actually do that at some point. For like the
last 3 years, just get all s- misconduct allegations for streamers,
put them all in a tier list, and rate
You'd have to figure out what you're rating them on though. Like
how good was the drama or like how much of a is the in question?
Like I you'd have to you'd have to figure out your criteria for
rating first. >> They won't say weird [__]
>> Rate them. Rate them.
Rate them.
Which
sexual deviant had the best aura? Which one aura aura formed
hardest?
Epstein rated at the top. Let's go. Not a streamer though.
>> It's okay. It's going to be only up from here. This
is the worst What happened? What's the worst >> I mean
Chud Logic's got to be up there, right? Pretty close to S tier.
Like people don't even Unless you're from outside the community,
people don't even remember that there was like an age allegation
or I don't. I basically all I hear is jokes, okay? He turned
that all into a
Turned himself into a chaser to avoid the other
far more egregious allegations, which I I don't believe are true
at all. I've never gone through that drama start to finish, so
it may it feels weird for me to just say like that's obviously
fake. So I've I've just never gone through it start to finish.
So I'm not I'm not casting doubt. I A lot of people I like respect
and trust their ability to analyze things say it's like yeah,
he just didn't know didn't know anything there, so but I I feel
weird saying it myself if I don't know for sure. Think before
you sleep brought it up the allegations up. Yeah, I know. I asked
him if he's got to finish for Yassify tricks under that tweet.
I know that, Nikandros.
He does, by the way. >> First that already came.
You only go up now. And it's slowly coming out, so you're
>> You're real streamer if you don't have a
Yeah, I think you can manage. Speed just Speed just threatened
okay? Speed doesn't actually have a Well, no, Speed's got a controversy.
Never mind. Kai Cenat's got the friend who Well, well,
what can you do?
Yeah, who going to stop me? WHO GOING TO STOP ME? YOU GUYS DON'T
remember the Kai Cenat? Sorry, I should speed. I'm not racist.
>> I know, Chad. It's a lot to process.
I like sitting here. Bro, this is awkward. This is giga awkward.
[__] me. >> I don't even know how you're processing.
It's insane. It's mental.
>> It's a lot to process all the time.
I do listen to Phil Collins a lot.
>> I actually do.
>> Okay, bro. Okay, bruh.
Don't ever date an internet girl again. >> I promise you
I will never date an internet girl again.
>> Oh, [snorts] come on, man. >> want to.
>> Get back up on that horse.
Mhm. To lock in and analyze the psychology between them, is she
even doing her best job keeping him stable?
Uh nah, boring.
He's boring. All I All I can think
We 8 minutes or so. >> Who much
All I can think whenever I like look at this person is this.
I'm sorry.
>> I know Chad, it's just a lot to process.
>> It's too much. I don't even know how you process it.
>> It's insane. It's mental.
>> It's too much. >> Sleep. Sleep.
This is all I can think of every single time, man. It's crazy.
It's just like it's uncanny. It's
>> I don't even know how you process it.
It's insane. It's mental.
>> What? IT'S NOT RACIST.
BRO, IT'S LITERALLY not racist at all. What the [__]
are you talking about?
How are you How are you going to tell me this is racist?
How are you going to tell me this is racist? It's like the same
person.
It's like the exact same person.
>> It's a lot to process all the time.
I do listen to Phil Collins a lot.
>> I actually do. >> All right, 48 minutes. My bad.
We're moving forward. I think he's going back to LSF here in
just a second. Yeah. It's an hour time. Back here to LSF to Fight
in the trenches. Are you saying she's a bug person? I am not.
I can't tell what's more racist than this. Mindset saying [__]
the armor referring to Emiru. Oh, this or >> mindset saying
>> I'm really not. I I I know I act like a piece of [__]
on stream. I I I I'm really not. Like in person I tell you I'm
not a piece of [__] Like I really am not. I swear
I'm not. Have I [__] up a lot of times in my [__]
life? Yes. >> Red bucket. >> But I'm I'm not a piece
of [__] >> Just a dono. What the [__]
>> I'm a cocky dick, yeah, but I'm not a I'm not a piece
of [__] IRL. I'm really not. Like I don't I don't
ever try to hurt other people or perp people.
I I don't do that.
>> That doesn't mean anything. >> troll a lot. Like
I troll >> doesn't mean anything. >> too much.
>> Some of the most harmful people in social situations
or that I become friends with are people who don't intend to
harm.
Like it's That doesn't mean anything. >> But I I don't
I'm not a I don't want to dick
>> I don't know anything about him. He's always been very
nice to me. Always had Always been perfectly nice to me. Checks
in once in a while and just says, "Hey, what's going on? What's
going on with Wow all this?" Always been perfectly nice to me.
So, I I have nothing but good experiences with Miz. But I'm just
saying that like when somebody says, "I'm I'm I'm nice. I'm like
always nice to people." I'm like that means nothing. I'll be
the judge of that once we get to know each other. >> I
think he's a human garbage piece of >> Two days ago. >> that
you guys have to deal with this [__] as a community.
I hate this [__] for you guys. I really do. I >> No,
you don't. No, you don't. >> that I've seen people throw
away their [__] merch and just be like, "I'm done
with him." I hate that.
I hate that
you guys can't like talk about me and like I'm afraid to talk
to other streamers and I hate all this [__] I hate
that you guys are like
>> That's some You shouldn't validate it. That's some You
shouldn't validate it.
>> It's I don't It's It sucks, dude. >> I don't know.
>> Miz is cute and funny. >> I know. I I feel like
I said I >> He's cute and funny, okay? He's just cute and
funny. He's just cute and >> the charity you guys. I do.
I owe you guys a lot.
And I know sometimes on stream I can be either angry and [__]
chat. I I've
I'm really stressed.
A lot.
And small things kind of like make me just get like stressed
nowadays cuz >> Just all this [__] What if
the penguin got bogged? The penguin is bogged, man. What are
you talking about? Look at the cheeks on that penguin.
>> If I could buy all your Yo Merch, I
>> LSF removed it? Why?
Harmful misinformation of seriously misleading titles.
>> I understand exactly why that would make him crash out
or upset. But man, it's not worth caring about at >> She
said it wasn't sexual. She said it was her mis- it was her own
emotional
>> Cry. King Daddy PD got her back. >> Why is this
That's fair. How is it fair that she can go live and accuse me
of this [__] And it's totally fine to leave up there.
But but you remove this? Or Or what about the clips where people
were trying to ruin my life with me getting mad at Sinner and
[__] Or anything else. You But you remove
Just change the title and do it again, chat. Change the title
and do it again.
There's no way.
Change the title and do it again.
>> Orange Kush, you need to chill, bro. That's [__]
That's a gross comment, man.
We do love Mizkif. >> Do whatever you need to say, dude.
>> Payment time. Okay, bro.